un homme et son mur de sacs de sable
insuffisant pour stopper la vente de
l'eau l'eau passe en dessous
ces cinq là et ça va dans mon sous sol
l'eau frôle le plancher de son sous sol
comme en 2017
sa conjointe et lui avaient alors été
obligés de quitter leur domicile quatre
mois le temps de réparer les dégâts
il n'a pas le goût de revivre cette
épreuve pour la deuxième fois en trois
ans mettre les émotions de côté et puis
les chiots à ce qu'on peut faire au
point de vue pratique des brochets
pourquoi pour avoir le même problème
l'année prochaine donc aujourd'hui je
dirais qu'on est bien parce que là on a
envie de faire confiance la crainte
d'une répétition du scénario de 2010 est
en même ceux qui comme josé morais n'ont
pas encore subi de dégâts cette année on
est à l'écouté pompe ça ça va tu prends
pessac ont produit pas on va se
réveiller avec de l'eau jusqu'à lors
comme d'autres ici elle n'a pas été
informé des risques d'inondation lors de
l'achat en 2005 est ici la possibilité
de recevoir une indemnité pour déménager
n'est que c'est absolument personne
c'est ce qui me reste à payer du potec
en prenez vous allez breistroff huriez
mes voisins et moi on va aller vivre
chez monsieur legault pour notre
retraite ont dû renforcer la digue
la ville de laval envoie chez michel
roux des travailleurs pour renforcer sa
digue
regardez mais le propriétaire leur
explique que davantage de sable ne
changera rien ici le salut passe plutôt
par 7 pompes qui éloigne l'eau du sous
sol refait l'an passé et les sommes
proposées par québec semble aussi
insuffisantes les maisons comme ça ça
vous même pas intérêt n'était remo deux
fois ça en plus des questionnements
quant aux montants proposés il existe
une réelle inquiétude quant à la vitesse
à laquelle les remboursements pourraient
être faits la plupart des citoyens que
nous avons rencontrés
soit que le processus soit plus rapide
qu'en 2010 est ici david john dilley
radio-canada laval